c'est un week-end ou le snowboard est
roi une occasion encore bien rares les
plus aguerris à coeur joie
j'aime bien l'esprit du snowboard c'est
cool relax on se prend pas la tête et
puis les seuils de donner le meilleur de
soi-même voilà quoi mais pour donner le
meilleur de soi même
il faut comme il se doit acquérir les
bases mais bon bien tes bras allez c'est
parti à commencer par équipes première
chute premières sensations ses enfants
découvrent le snowboard ou jeudi aurait
vécu c'est un petit peu plus guère mes
skis que le second alors c'est pour ça
que j'ai voulu essayer et ça me plaît
c'est plus rigolo
oui parce que tu prends le chemin des
gamelles alors ce plus rigolo c'est
c'est plus le mois de en ce moment avec
mon corps en ont fait on fait du style
manga recevra paris soutenu par sa maman
jérémy 11 ans aura passé toute sa
journée la planche au pied et malgré les
difficultés propres à tout apprentissage
c'est sûr il va persévérer
c'était son choix c'était des plus
question de remonter sur les skis
maintenant qu'il a et c'est justement
des quatre en cinq ans les enfants enfin
les parents à nous amènent leurs enfants
donc c'est vrai que dans un premier
temps nous on conseille plutôt parlant
de leur faire faire du ski l'objectif de
ces gamins c'est cela rejoindre sur la
neige et dans les airs ce qu'ils ont
appris à mépriser cette disciple
une li synonyme de liberté